we're here at the university of
california santa barbara
to discuss a dream of humanity the
ability to exit our solar system
and enter another solar system and the
solution
is literally before your eyes so i have
two things on me that you have i have a
watch
and i have a flashlight which if it's
not on you it's on your phone
so the watch keeps time and my
flashlight
just illuminates my environment so like
art
to me science is illuminating i want to
see reality in a different way
when i turn on the flashlight suddenly
the dark becomes bright and i suddenly
see
the flashlight emits light you can see
coming out the light on my hand
is not only illuminating my hand it's
actually pushing on my hand
light carries energy and momentum so the
answer is not to make a spacecraft out
of a flashlight
by having the exhaust come out this way
and the spacecraft goes that way that's
what we do today with chemistry
the answer is this take the flashlight
and put it somewhere on the earth in
orbit or on the moon
and then shine it on a reflector which
propels
the reflector to speeds which can
approach the speed of light
well how do you make a flashlight that's
big enough this isn't going to do it my
hand's not
doesn't seem to be going anywhere and
that's because the force is very very
low
so the way that you can solve this
problem is taking many many flashlights
which are actually lasers
and synchronizing them in time and when
you gang them all together
into a gigantic array which we call a
phased array
you then have a sufficiently powerful
system which if you make it roughly the
size of a city
it can push a spacecraft which is
roughly the size of your hand to speeds
which are
roughly 25 percent the speed of light
that would enable us to get to the
nearest
star the proxima centauri which is a
little over four light years away
in less than 20 years the initial probes
will be roughly the size of your hand
and the size of the reflector that
you're going to use is going to be
roughly human size
so not a whole lot larger than myself
but a few meters in size
it only uses the reflection of light
from this very large laser ray to propel
the spacecraft
so let's let's talk about this this is a
lot like
sailing on the ocean when you sail on
the ocean you're pushed by
the wind and the wind then drives the
sail forward through the water
in our case we're creating an artificial
wind in space
from this laser ray except the wind is
actually the photons from the laser
itself the light
from the laser becomes the wind upon
which we sail
it is a very directed light it's often
called directed energy
so why is this possible today why can we
talk about going to the stars today
when 60 years ago when the space program
began in earnest
people would have said that's not
possible well the reason it's possible
today has a lot to do with the consumer
and the very fact that you're watching
me you're watching me over a high-speed
internet
which is dominated by the photonics of
sending data over fiber optics
photonics essentially allow the internet
to exist
in the way it does today the ability to
send vast amounts of data very quickly
is the same technology that we're going
to use to send
spacecraft very quickly to the stars you
effectively have an infinite supply of
propellant you can turn it on and off as
needed
you do not leave the laser array
that produces the light on for the
entire journey
for a small spacecraft it's only on for
a few minutes and then it's
like shooting a gun you have a
projectile which just moves
ballistically
even if we as humans are not on the
spacecraft at least we have the ability
to send
out such spacecraft you want to remotely
view
or have remote imaging and remote
sensing
of an object so when we go to jupiter
for example
with a flyby mission we are taking
pictures of jupiter we're measuring the
magnetic field the particle density
and we're basically exploring remotely
the same way that you are looking at me
and all of the current missions that are
beyond the moon
are remote sensing emissions what would
we hope to find if we visit an exoplanet
perhaps there's life on an exoplanet and
we would be able to see evidence of life
either through atmospheric biosignatures
or through
you know a dramatic picture would be
able to see something actually on the
surface
we don't know if there's life elsewhere
in the universe perhaps on the missions
that we send out we will find evidence
for life perhaps we will not and while
economics may seem like an inappropriate
thing to bring into
a talk on interstellar capability it is
in fact one of the driving
issues in achieving interstellar
capability
you have to get things to the point
where they're economically affordable
to do what we want to do so currently we
have
systems in the lab which have achieved
the ability to synchronize
over very large scales out to about
10 kilometers or roughly six miles we've
been able to achieve synchronization of
laser systems
and it's worked beautifully we know how
to build
lasers for many decades but it's only
now that the technology has gotten
inexpensive enough
and become mature enough that we can
imagine
having huge arrays literally
kilometer scale arrays much like solar
farms
but instead of receiving light they
transmit light
the beauty of this type of technology is
it enables
many applications not just relativistic
flight for small spacecraft but enables
high-speed spacecraft high-speed flight
in our solar system
it enables planetary defense it enables
space debris removal
enables powering of distant assets that
we
may want to send power to such as
spacecraft or bases
on the moon or other places it's an
extremely versatile technology
it's something the humanity would want
to develop even if they didn't want to
send spacecraft to the stars
because that technology allows so many
applications that are currently not
feasible and therefore i feel it's an
inevitable technology because we have
the ability
we just need to fine-tune the technology
and in a sense wait
for economics to catch up with us so it
becomes
cheap enough to build the large systems
the smaller systems
are affordable now and we've already
started building prototype systems in
our lab
so while it's not going to happen
tomorrow we've already begun the process
and so far it's looking good this isn't
both a revolutionary program in terms of
being
a transformative technology but it's
also an evolutionary
program so personally i do not expect to
be
around when the first relativistic
flight happens
i think that's probably 30 plus years
off before we get to that point and
perhaps
perhaps more but what inspires me is to
look
at the ability to achieve the final
goals even if it does not happen in my
lifetime
it can happen in the lifetime of the
next generation or the generation beyond
that
the consequences are so transformative
that we literally in my opinion must go
down this path we must explore what the
limitations are and then how do we
overcome the limitations
the search for life on other planets
would be one of humanity's
foremost explorations and
if we're able to do so and actually find
life on another planet
it would change humanity forever
everything is profound in life if you
look deep enough you'll find something
incredibly complex and interesting and
beautiful in life
and the same is true with the lowly
photon that we use to
to see every day but when we look
outside and we imagine something vastly
greater
an array of lasers that are synchronized
we can imagine things which are just
extraordinary
in life and the ability to go to another
star is one of those extraordinary
capabilities
[Music]
you